cette situation à kiev la capitale et la
situation reste du pays en tête aller un
peu plus à l'est avec ses images dans la
ville de zappos reggie est largement
épargné jusque là étaient visés aussi
par des frappes ça pour lg c'est la
destination du couloir humanitaire qui a
été instauré à marioupol une destination
comme on le dit refuge pour ces
centaines de milliers d'habitants de
cette ville portuaire assiégée par les
forces russes ont leur appel malgré tout
il y avait quand même un succès on va
parler ainsi vingt mille quatre cent
mille civils bloqués qui ont réussi à
s'extirper 1 tout à fait c'est à dire
que jusqu'à hier si vous voulez y avait
deux de récits 1 qui s'affrontaient il y
avait les ukrainiens et les autorités
locales notamment qu'ils disaient en
fait quand les russes nous disent qu'il
faut un cessez le feu ils sont montre en
main et au bout de 20 minutes cessez le
feu est terminée donc techniquement on
peut évacuer personnes les russes de
leur côté disent que en réalité ce sont
les nationalistes ukrainiens qui
retiennent les civils de partir pour
quoi qu'il en soit effectivement on a
vingt mille civils qui ont pu quitter
marioupol d'autres rappellent qu'elle
est terriblement assiégée depuis depuis
au moins une semaine à la fois en fait
elle est totalement encerclé à la fois
par la terre est à la fois par la mer
donc il ya vingt mille civils qui ont pu
partir dans une colonne la hausse il
faut s'en rend compte de 4000 véhicules
vers cette ville de sapporo jay qui se
situe qui se situent globalement par ici
alors à protéger on en a déjà parlé si
vous vous souvenez au début du conflit
au début de cette invasion russe les
l'armée russe avait pris la centrale
nucléaire de la ville qui est la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe mais
il n'était pas rentré dans la vie donc
ces réfugiés là sont allés à sapporo jay
qui jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'était pas
attendre par les bombardements et alors
je sais pas si lundi matin écrit jusqu'à
ce matin et alors est ce que c'est un
hasard du calendrier est ce que c'est
volontaire en tout cas à la gare donc
l'un des moyens de transport qui permet
de sortir de cette ville de sapporo jay
a été atteint par des bombardements donc
c'est un peu paradoxal finalement
l'accord qui a été trouvé d'évacuer des
civils vers sapporo jay et le
bombardements sur la ville qui a suivi
ces gars qui savent aussi d'abris pour
les civic ceux qui n'ont pas de cave où
se réfugier au moment où les sirènes
retentissent merci bilal sur le front
sud